good good morning gamers welcome back to
Minecraft today it's a very sad day
Jurgen is no more we only have peepee
poo-poo hey peepee poo-poo literally no
one cares peepee poo-poo today is a day
where we bring our boys back okay Sven
is stuck in this portal and I don't I
don't what the Frick
oh my gosh I don't have arrows this is
bad
Sven can you move please Sven I cannot
stand losing another pet please come
follow me son
oh my gosh how do I make him go through
stop sitting how did you how did he even
get here okay my dog is stuck okay
apparently mine cards work I'm coming
IKEA bird we have to get them back a
very important day don't worry Sven
we're gonna get you out of why can't I
place the minecart do I need to actually
place it on its van what about a boat
okay so then here we go don't be scared
I don't think it's working
yes go go go go go go come here you
smiley smiley pie Lee come on
chief believe it listen we've been
looking for a ddr4 a long time to spend
you're the new DJ now stay there I have
to go find we have to go find dinnerbone
ASAP ride like the wind peepee poo-poo
ride like the wind
okay maybe not but could be came fast
all the sudden it's that right peepee
poo-poo whoa
I never seen a just randomly
that's so weird what are you selling
blue bubble coral not Taylor sell that's
perfect I just need that okay you you
know go ding-dongs ming mahn go down go
down to your in the hole say with PP pop
oh I need that super bad how do I do
this
okay people put will you stay there oh
my gosh how do I do this
no I've been waiting for an optical Asst
cell there we go stay there and people
will you stay as well
I know IKEA bird I don't like doing this
but I need I need the cash
daddy's short on cash don't ask
questions
gosh please don't do spawn please don't
do spawn they better still be here yes
yes what are you doing with your llama
dude ah okay
epic I won't say anything about you in
the llama doing the chiki chiki bang
bang
are you scared you wanna be frank I
forgot the shells I gotta run back if
only I had a horse or something
if only where there was a horse just
like your again do you know how long
every wanted to make this ever since I
saw that you can make it I want to make
it okay do you know how I want to make
it for a very long time okay so now we
can finally make finally I should have a
couple Bing bong bong bong a conduit am
I right or am i right well what will
wool
I don't I think this makes it so that we
can breathe underwater dan that was
expensive dude I don't want to die with
this on me ah gosh I missed your again
there will never be another yard again
okay people let's go
how does conduits work I have no idea Oh
like you know how to make a conduit
three people who you didn't even know
how to wipe your own butt okay can you
shut your pee-pee I'm trying to get
there oh you think there's a more
efficient way to go by all means peepee
poo-poo by all means look here's water
shut up and sick of your attitude peepee
poo-poo yeah that's right this bet I
doesn't connect okay
ah Frick
right would you get out just get out
we're gonna freakin find him douche what
happened to this minecraft seriously
people booth it used to be so simple now
it's just you and me left and no as a
near the only dispensable character that
I dare to bring with me at this point
why you really wanted me to say it out
loud in you don't stop crying baby poop
oh my god whoa that was awesome
yeah you can't do that even if you've
lost all your weight pee pee poop we
don't even pretend like you're someone
that you're not
whoa that was awesome
okay so now we're gonna use the conduit
I don't want to waste it so I might do a
little google snuggle just to make sure
I know what I'm doing
Frick if it wasn't for all this C stuff
it wouldn't even be a problem all right
con people who you stay in the boat I
need you to hold down the boat live
slurp slurp
alright let's find this dude conduit
whoa off dolphin helping me thanks
dolphin all right we got a look as well
let's say she get rid of all these see
stuff gosh damn I'm fast and I'm slow
all right let's try and place the condom
wow that is so cool
Wow guys I'm so glad I did this I'm so
glad I spent all my what is oh my god
does it not go away no material objects
don't matter
I need peepee poo-poo oh my god are you
kidding me you cannot be serious
it might be just cuz its water right yes
just cause it's water it's coming up
cool where the Frick am i okay you guys
on this subreddit told me X minus 275
what that makes no sense why - 599 you
guys what are you sloping
that's so far away it's got a fishing
rod
shoot him hey can you help me I'm trying
to find my friend dude okay $5.99 and
then what is down yeah
whoa whoa whoa that is so cool I don't
have time to check this out okay $5.99 I
got to stay on this plane
I'm sorry about punching you oh thanks
bros nine-year-olds you did it
incredible jobs Oh subarashii
yes I'm so sorry dude your skin must be
so wrinkly you've been here so long dude
Bing Bing Bing Bing get me up let me act
[Applause]
that's what I'm freakin talkin about
I'll tickle you as much as I want in
there bow and I'll tickle ear as much as
that wall I'll dig your hole quick hole
quick hold in there bone break up break
up break up stay there dinner
spinner Epic dinner I gotta try
something so you guys have been saying
this forever
that if I feed a dolphin and there's so
many dolphins here so I assume that has
to be something here a little dolphin
come here oh my god wait up he's gonna
show me the way to a treasure maybe I
need more fish for him this is how we
fish in Sweden by the way how did he
survive a diamond punch what how strong
are these fishes don't make me put you
in a bucket oh my gosh it actually
worked
dolphin showed me map to treasure
wow what we were epic it's gravel you
showed gravel all right now show me the
treasure show me the treasure you
dolphin he sparkling he sparkling that
much means something he pooped up
something what are you doing oh he's
playing with it
that's so awesome whoa dolphin show
treasure epically thanks dolphin you're
the best my god Wow Wow
what a treasure guys can't wait to show
your heritage whoa okay
gamers be jealous I can't wait to show
you all the speed on this unit
baby poopoo baby poopoo I found it I
found the treasure
I mean it's dinner but I found in their
book boys are back boys are back
hey Sven play that music obviously we're
missing the two most important I would
argue three people of this plane through
the heroes that died for our costs for
our country for our brawl and the heroes
that will always be remembered everyone
kept saying motor ship water ship you
built a church for Watership you built
giant meatball for water sheep what did
you do for uragan what have you done for
year again well today we're changing
name today we're building a year again
memorial
it's that right spin happy times
everyone happy time sorry I'm going to
bed what's up gamers it's me I'm back
what's up IKEA berth how you doing
staying whole spent you come with me so
I have something to admit okay I've made
an oopsie I basically added I cheated
okay I cheated I'm sorry I feel what
does it feel like I've done something
awful when I was memeing with the pigs
I changed the game mode so I can't get
more potatoes how do you think it was a
big deal I think it probably isn't a big
deal for a lot of people but since some
people were bothered by it and I can
kind of understand the whole like okay
well if you cheat on this thing did he
actually built the meatballs yes I built
the meatball stop saying that
even though most people don't care and
they're like I just have fun playing the
game I want to stick I want to stay true
to - what the - what the series is so I
promise I pray this is a PewDiePie
promise I will not never not on my spare
time not another thing use it okay just
so we're clear I prom I promise I
thought today that I was gonna build a
memorial for year again and show me
actually building it so you will
actually believe me that I built this
thing okay so I know most people don't
care about that the whole creative mode
thing but I really care about this
playthrough and I know a lot of people
do as well so and I feel like it only
makes sense for me to build this for
uragan and do it the right way
I'm gonna need some spruce Panks but
it's gonna be worth it cuz Jurgen was a
spruce II guy
yeah that looks good
what do you guys think hey there's men
we're doing this for your again yeah I'm
pretty sure I can't build this with dirt
I'm gonna need to make Spain I'm gonna
have to make bamboo
let's go gamer let's make bamboo and
have some shampoo now where is the
bamboo
oh yeah cuz he makes scaffolding see I
know how to do this don't worry about it
Bing bong Bing Bing Bing bong
so I'm following another pattern I'll
show it I'm gonna try to change that up
a little bit so it feels more like mine
but I'm not trying to pretend like I
came up with this back no get dumped
back here eat eat eat Satan
no please how do you get up here go down
oh my god Sven get down from there come
on teleport you could seriously hurt
yourself spend please
Sven I have a bucket you're going in the
bucket come down for there or there will
be bucket oh my god I can't even build I
can't even be in a safe spot okay
Poppy's gonna push you spend don't worry
it's gonna be fine
Oh God oh eight eight eight eat it I
saved your life Spain
[Music]
my goal is for it to not look like a
dinosaur but I don't think he's working
Jurgen the Dino remember him you
remember the dinosaur I wrote in
Minecraft you guys remember him get him
here again
I mean Sven get him spin go get him go
get him spend go
you did it spin good job I can't really
see it's annoying with the bamboo like
it's in the way but I think it's
starting to come to place it looks a bit
strange but so I'm eating energy
crystals with G fuel they're really good
I'm not gonna lie bamboo it's kind of
annoying me at some point it's stupid
wow what baby saved me I held that shift
thanks baby
Jesus my new building is so dangerous Oh
Mike are you kidding me how spent what
happened spend KITT down please
okay jumps med jumps when it's okay it's
okay it's okay you can jump it safe you
get there how ow
just go just go there you go thank you
you're welcome
now it's sit there she blows
what a beauty I realized that I want the
flag to go on the other side because it
looks more badass
so yeah that's an easy fix when you're
up in the sky there she is
I'm really happy I think it's cool I
[Music]
think it's dope what do you guys think I
wish it was like diamond Armour but
maybe I'll change light in the future
but that's for year again now everyone
can stop saying right Sven everyone can
stop saying that I don't care about your
again because I built all this stuff for
what the sheep
okay so Sven
you're gonna have to hold down before it
ikea bird what do you what is she even
it's like a bird stuck like I don't know
just IKEA bird how do I save IKEA bird
oh my god please I can't bird I can't do
this I can't lose anyone else
wait let's read help me Felix you have
to go back to jungle and find another
real IKEA bird okay cool I didn't know
you spoke but yeah alright that's unfair
ah Frank what are you it was the jungle
I forgot son do you know where the
jungle is oh my god what is that it's a
little baby one that is so cool
everyone keeps saying I should take one
of these and name the Mary Hamm and I'm
like I'm so mad I didn't think of that
okay it should be this portal but it
might get me to the actual what what is
wrong with me just pick me save me from
lava see it takes me to the stronghold
which is which is technically in the
jungle so it's fine here we are in the
jungle baby okay I need the wood is that
an ikea bird then I just spot an IKEA
bird it's a baby I can't bird do
something
listen ain't got time for you I haven't
revealed yet what I need the jungle wood
for just look at that noise but once you
find out what I'm using jungle wood for
you're gonna crime there will be tears
shed IKEA bird what's up IKEA bird
friend what is a green bird
jacksepticeye green pewdiepie bird oh I
don't have seeds for you oh my god we
have to get green pewdiepie alright I'll
be one side then that's a lot of wood
dude I'm freaking Tarzan baby okay wait
what was I looking for it yeah I want
melons I need seeds what is this it's
like a safe haven there's so many
flowers oh my god you must be like a
holy sheep or something hello holy Sh
hello holy sheep how are you oh wow holy
sheep disappeared that's so strange
I have bait whoa what is this why is
there so many flowers oh man if Juergen
saw this boy would he like this Jurgen
loved flowers it was his favorite thing
hey white guy is that finally pink dye
pink dye orange dye wow this is so
pretty
oh my god oh my god up right next to
jungle look look look look look look
they are all living here in harmony this
is so nice you like flowers
we got them so what happens if I burn
down the forest
Oh Oh actually I don't know if I want to
I don't know if I want to do that Oh Oh
my god what is happen whoa
freakin random holes in the freaking
ground are you kidding me
bye
oh god he's coming after me stop
following me
stop following me I called the fires out
problem solved melon yes yes I found you
oh I heard birdy-bird could it be idea
bird really like here bird token ii desu
ka' ikea bird son ikea bird for real
beautiful your graceful Your Honor I
have cocoa beans do you like coke up
smoke oh of course he likes cocoa is
from Ikea you don't eat cocoa while you
eat
Melo no okay that's one too
three how many do you want like I'd
rather keep some of these come on I
can't bear it leveled with me
IKEA bird this is a crazy thing because
I know I forgot to put the name on the
nametag dang it
alright fine you come with me we just
gotta find our way out of here
I do need more melon there and I'm gonna
have to I think I'm gonna have to kill
the other IKEA i just think i yes melons
give it to me give me those melons thank
you you see this IKEA bird staying with
me has its privileges there it is
okay see I told you I told you I care
bird nothing to worry about
once we gone the real IKEA fish this
playthrough will be completed if only I
could get an Ikea dog come on
yes oh my god your sword to find kiss
you're so sneaky licking all right we
have a ton of melon damn this guy is a
real snake aren't you
how much melon dizzy
how much melon do you want love me okay
you have a problem all right you're
gonna have to sit here for a while until
the comments tell me what to do stay
back at a kea bird what are you even
ah they're spawning everywhere what's
that
Ron IKEA bar they're crazy okay through
the portal egg here bird let's jump
through the portal thank you he went Oh
God oh yes oh I can't bird do not do nut
I repeat job he jumped in me oh there
you are
okay God my hub is ugly okay and I
through the portal like a bird don't be
scared it's fine look web Thank You bird
yeah you can slick my poopy you know
what
stay there really like here IKEA bird
number two how about die alright here we
go
BAM oh yeah wait him get away from you
again okay I'm running okay I'm done
time to sleep
okay I know this is kind of blasphemous
I get it
I promise you what they're sheep you're
gonna dig this okay let's make sure I do
this right this is very important stuff
[Music]
what am i building IKEA bread don't
worry don't worry none of your concern
nation looks awful well just wait
anything here we go yeah we should have
water coming out of his mouth oh my gosh
yes is there pink material
what's the pink material they even have
pink I am a Liam I have it I have one
beep peony pink dye pink dye I have it I
don't have to go back to the jungle
amazing and then a Liam might be good to
actually ha ha oh my gosh I love it so
much I like how I spent an hour and a
half
building this and I'm like this is
awesome I've slime so I think this is
might be possible but I never done this
before so for this to work this would
have to be activated when it reaches
this point which big brain ah eat the
melon suck it up I feel like I should
have ended this episode very long ago
but I I have to do this now I just have
to do this yeah I key a bird no I can't
bird escape stop him stop him you will
never escape your prison fake IKEA bird
cry as much as you like you are here
forever does that mean I can rewire this
I don't see why not
IKEA bird get out away please
[Music]
yes yes it work
big brain okay okay okay okay okay Kay
Kay Kay
so put that there that there god I hope
this works let's try it Sven yes yes
epic all right all right all right all
right you have to acknowledge he's
spitting straight in water right now I'm
so happy all right we're gonna add that
episode there
excuse me DJ DJ IKEA all you decided to
come now yeah universe then thanks for
watching another episode of minecraft
hope you guys enjoyed smash like check
out the merch very epic I appreciate it
thank you and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]